18 juin 1979 date de la première
émission pirates enregistré par rbs deux
ans plus tard la radio du vexin et du
val de seine se voit attribuer une
fréquence lors de la libéralisation des
ondes elle est aujourd'hui l'une des
plus vieilles radios de france j'ai pu
voir radio de france la pub radio
associative de france qui à l'époque
était pirates en 79 et en 1980 lorsque
le président mitterrand a libéré les
radios nous sommes nous devenus donc
voilà officiel et puis bien jusqu'à
maintenant en 2021 nous sommes toujours
là sur la bande fm 96.2 fm je suis dépit
la création de la radio depuis 1979
avant on était clandestins on le faisait
dans les caves dans les maisons dont
dont un peu partout et on était
poursuivi par une voiture et à une pas
la gorge qui nous cherchait et vous
savez on n'était pas libre la liberté
d'expression et faire connaître les
différentes cultures représentent les
deux lignes conductrices de la radio
depuis 42 ans l'esprit de la radio libre
ça c'est très très très important la
radio libre c'est quoi pour nous c'est
le droit de parole
ou donner à tout à tout le monde à
toutes les communautés à à toutes les
associations et faire connaître aussi
les différentes cultures destinations
soleil bonjour bonjour à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue sur votre fréquence 96
points de fmr vs point fr pour ceux qui
nous écoutent depuis loin dans le dans
les îles et puis d'endo dans le monde et
au fil des ans la radio a su développer
une proximité avec ses auditeurs
quand on fait l'émission etalk aux
pillards est régulièrement une auditrice
qui m'appelle il n'y a je vous écoute je
vous écoute où j'ai pas eu le temps d'en
temps le début mais je suis là je suis
là je vous écoute c'est bien bravo on
fait la radio pas pour se faire plaisir
mais pour faire plaisir aux auditeurs
c'est ça qui est très important composée
d'une trentaine de bénévoles et d'une
salariée la radio du vexin et du val de
seine a encore de belles années devant
elle